عقوبه اوروبيه تنهال وعلى راس النظام
الايراني لم تعد تطال 40 شخصيه وسبع
مؤسسات ايرانيه كما في السابق بل اضاف
عليها الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد اجتماعه في
بروكسل 20 شخصيه اخرى وتلفزيون الايراني
في قائمه العقوبات ضد طهران بيان الاتحاد
الاوروبي كان قلبا وقالبا ضد قمع النظام
الايراني المنهج واستخدامه القوه المفرطه
ضد المحتاجين وضم صوته الى صفوفهم دائما
تطلعات المنطفدين لنيل الحريه حيث دعى
البيان الى وقف الاعتقالات التي وصفها
بالعشوائيه وتهدف الى اسكات صوت المعارضين
وادانا الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا تنفيذ ايران
عقوبه الاعدام بحق المحتجين مطالبا باجراء
تحقيقات مستقله حول حمله قمع الاحتجاجات
لم يكن البيان الاوروبي خاليا من تعاون
ايران ايضا مع روسيا لان الدول الاوروبيه
اذنت باسرها اي دعم عسكري تقدمه طهران الى
موسكو بما في ذلك المسيارات واعتبرته
انتهاكا خطيرا لمبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده
وحذر الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران من عواقب اي
دعم عسكري اضافي الى روسيا وخاصه مساله
احتمال تزويدها بالصواريخ البالستيه واكد
بيان الاتحاد الاوروبي ان ايران تواصل
نشاطات زعزعت استقرار منطقه الشرق الاوسط
من خلال تزويد اطراف حكوميه وغير حكوميه
بالمسيرات والاسلحه المتقدمه وان الاتحاد
الاوروبي عازمون على منع ايران من الوصول
للسلاح النووي
[موسيقى]